hello dr. Berger I had another question
related to bulletproof coffee this keeps
coming up so I'm just gonna do a little
video on this to give you my opinion on
this so what's a bulletproof coffee
it's coffee with added butter or coconut
oil and it's blended and then you drink
that in the morning as a like a meal
replacement and the fat allows you to go
a long period of time I think it's
actually a good thing to start out with
this because that fat really allows you
to go the whole morning without being
hungry for most people and it's a it's a
great first step so I think you should
do this you don't have to but it's not a
bad idea because the other option is
just to have a meal and then push your
meal an hour later an hour later an hour
later as you get used to this to the
point where often you're just having two
meals and that's the ideal scene is to
have like like two meals for most people
they can do very well in that because of
the principle every time you eat you
spike in fun now it is true that this
bulletproof coffee will trigger insulin
a little bit okay it does even though
fats don't trigger insulin it's neutral
but the fact that it triggers a stomach
the stomach releases hormones that then
trigger insulin okay that's what it is
it's not the actual material so it's
it's more of a stomach action now I
I suggest you start with this as one
option you you don't have to but it's
not a bad idea and then what I recommend
is when you become key to adapted when
things get more comfortable and you're
all out and you can go longer pairs of
time without being hungry and you have
no more cravings for sweets and you have
a lot of energy not getting tired after
you eat you're not needing for sweets
after you eat key to adapt it then you
may want to replace the butter I mean in
the butter of the coconut oil with maybe
half-and-half or cream okay a little
cream just because that would lower
insulin even more and that way it's not
like you've been having any insulin
spike you can go right from here to here
without any instant spike at all so as
you transition you might want to Nick
this and the reason for that is some
people find that this could kind of
prevent them from maximizing their
weight-loss okay it's just because of
the the extra fat there because what we
want to do is get you key to adapted to
the point where you're basically burning
your own fat okay that's the goal so
you're gonna find you eat a meal you can
you're gonna need a lot less fat dietary
fat you're gonna find this that's too
much fat and you're not gonna need as
much after the meal because or are you
gonna feel a little nauseous so you
really want to adjust that and you're
gonna find that you need less and less
because you're burning your own fat
between the meals and it's a great
situation because you you slim down but
you it's a much better fuel source if
you're trying to gain weight maybe you
want to keep it in but the only point is
that this potentially could slow you
down a little bit okay that's my opinion
and I'm sticking to it
thanks for watching hey you probably
already subscribed but if you haven't
press this little button down below and
I will keep you updated